it is with all sorts of lucidity and
consciousness that we need to deal with
this situation you would easily be
giving your body a song and the European
Union together and needs to deal with
the fighter against the trafficking of
bombs don't deny typically we need the
French president you can ever on you the
determination is determined as is the
rest of France to beat the terrorism in
war I thought it was small I saw sleep
the way of themselves the police almost
all our police services will deal with
the situation as sensibly as possible
for people s be directed to the war
believe that your goals in a bush people
and they will undertake enough the
situation that the terror levels will be
as elevated as possible